richard berry 2 mde alors vous jean-paul
dans ce pays vous avez un look un peu à
la mia frye dreadlocks vous dit
happy face happy face happy face à
biesheim tout le temps 12 janvier au
body ouais je veux dire bouge ton corps
voilà vous êtes bien je suis prof de je
suis prof de gym en fait un jeu et
j'entraîne les enfants je fais une
chorégraphie pour les enfants mais je
leur parle comme si j'avais 15 ans de
danse ses 18 ans l'annexé nationale le
cloneur face à jean-paul oui une
question qui pourra vous semblez
peut-être un petit peu indiscrètes
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui vous
attend le soir chez vous pas encore prêt
non je suis je suis je peux faire une
annonce ou pas hier mais je veux bien
mais chez les personnes qui m'attend
donc avec les yeux vous avez vous avez
vous avec moi maintenant c'est bizarre
je dédie ce film vous avez les cheveux
longs je sais pas si ça fait donc oui
donc je fais je peux faire une annonce
officielle
c'est un animateur ou une animatrice a
quand même de préférence
voilà je suis une annonce donc vous
pouvez m'appeler vous vous appelez là
dans l'appareil avait la preuve
jean paul donne tranche d'âge c'est un
concert à sydney entre dit non c'est
trop vie entre dix huit et dix huit et
demi
la blonde brûlé beaucoup d'expérience
expériences l'ont bruyamment mais
beaucoup l'extérieur peu importe ça me
fait super plaisir
voilà la semaine dernière enfin il ya
quinze jours on a marié godrèche et
bermond godrèche et d'armes il m'a fait
ça d'art aux voitures et tout le monde